[Music]
13 reasons why is renewed for a second
season Selena Gomez teased on social
media quote their story isn't over I'm
about to tell you the story of my life
more specifically why my life ended
Netflix announced the hit series will
return in 2018 with 13 more episodes the
show picking up after the characters
hear their tapes from Hannah why didn't
you say this to me when I was alive it's
quote the start of the characters
complicated journeys toward healing and
recovery according to a statement I
heard from the showrunner there might be
a season two of this has that been
talked about I don't know I don't know
honestly I would get in trouble for
saying something but I well that was
executive producer Selena Gomez playing
coy about rumors back in March
she told et at the LA premiere why she
thinks the teen drama is an important
story to tell and I want people to know
that every every single life is valuable
that their voice can be heard and other
people who are willing to be there for
them so is Alex okay could Tyler be
responsible for that fatal cliffhanger
in the final episode what other burning
questions do you hope to get answered in
season two leave your comments and stick
with it online
for the lady
[Music]
you